تسميها الشرطة الأسترالية المعجزة
التي كانوا يأملون
في إنقاذها قبل الفجر من كليو سميث البالغة من العمر أربع سنوات والتي
وجدت آمنة وسليمة بعد 18 يومًا
من فقدانها لأول مرة
لمحنة بدأت في
موقع التخييم البعيد هذا في 16 أكتوبر
، تقول والدة كليو في الأول  في
صباح رحلة تخييم عائلية ، استيقظت
لتجد ابنتها
ذهبت ، كانت الخيمة
مفتوحة تمامًا ، كانت على بعد حوالي 30 سم
من الفتح ،
وأعني أنني استدرت إلى جيك
وقلت للتو وكأن كلير ذهب
، أدى اختفاء الطفل إلى
مطاردة ذلك  انتشرت في جميع أنحاء البلاد
، حيث تقدم حكومة الولاية مكافأة قدرها مليون
دولار أسترالي للحصول على معلومات
تردد صداها في نداءات يائسة من عائلة كليو ،
كل ما نحتاجه حقًا هو القليل من العودة إلى
المنزل ،
أعلنت الشرطة أنها حلّت اللغز في
وقت مبكر من صباح يوم الأربعاء ، وتم تحقيق النتيجة
في حوالي الساعة 1 صباحًا من هذا الصباح
عندما
دخل أربعة ضباط وكسروا
الباب ووجدوا كليو صغيرًا في
غرفة وكما ترون
أنها على قيد الحياة
فهي بأمان  لقد عاد مع والدته وأبيها ،
ووجدتها الشرطة وحيدة في هذا المنزل في
كانافان ، مسقط رأس عائلتها ، على
بعد 30 ميلاً أو 48 كيلومترًا من
موقع التخييم الذي تعرفه ، أردت فقط أن
أكون متأكدًا تمامًا من أنه
يبدو بالتأكيد مثل كليو الذي
أريده  كن متأكدًا تمامًا من أنها هي ،
فقلت ما اسمك
لم تجب وقلت ما
اسمك تعرفها مرة أخرى ،
لذا سألتها للمرة الثالثة
ثم نظرت إلي ونظرت إلي وقالت
اسمي كلير
بوليس.  كليو لم تتعرض لأذى جسدي
وتم لم شملها بعد فترة وجيزة مع
والديها.الشرطة لديها رجل يبلغ من العمر 36 عامًا
لا علاقة له بأسرة كليو المحتجز حاليًا
، ويقولون إنهم يتوقعون توجيه اتهامات
بشأن ما وصفوه
باختطاف انتهازي قريبًا ،
وهو الإنقاذ الذي وصفه المسؤولون
نتيجة لطحن الشرطة القاسي الذي
شارك فيه 140 ضابط شرطة
يتم الاحتفال به الآن في جميع أنحاء
البلاد
ولكن الأهم من ذلك من
قبل
والدة كليو والدة كليو التي تعلن
أن عائلتنا كاملة  مرة أخرى
إيفان واتسون CNN